hello and welcome to take 4 of the
commentaries for gaudi we've been having
a little trouble with the equipment but
we'll try to keep it fresh and have the
conversation we just had again for you
that's LAN Eris he's filming for Joe
stars out this week and helped write the
trailer for Gotti and Dan the trout
Merle yes as always the air conditioning
is off we did 99% of this already under
which the real film gotti was in okay
this will be very rushed and haphazard
just like the film Gotti guys one more
time would we think again um the only
honest trailer we've done for a film
that I was in a Twitter feud with count
yeah that was fun a lot of movies
trailers like they're not well made and
this certainly falls under that that
category
but this is also it's just it's
reprehensible this movie it's a
despicable mood it is rotten to the core
it has no redeeming value in craft or
message right except to say here's a bad
guy and this is what happened to him and
it was any great folks don't you love
your am sorry the movie says look at
this awesome guy is doing horrible
things don't we love them yeah I mean we
this could have been two different
movies this could have been inside look
at the fall of the Mafia and this
particular family through the eyes of
God II who was in a very unique
standpoint or this could have been the
people's dawn why this man who would did
some very hain a committed murder this
movie shows him committing murder it's
not like oh maybe it's something no he
chose him committing multiple murders
why this man was so revered and and and
and and held up by the community right
this movie is neither of them I mean
here's nothing here's a thought is that
good bomb movies like Goodfellas which
they obviously stole and then and the
Godfather and even analyzed this sure
there's an outsider who's who's brought
into the mob and you're
through his eyes you're seeing a an
introduction to this world the secret of
underworld Henry Hill Michael Corleone
God God he just assumed Billy Crystal
you've been hanging out with Gotti for
your entire life
or so update on gaudy isms that you know
every lieutenant from every capo from
every mob boss it's a movie written for
people that already love Gotti and know
his story and don't need to be primed or
caught up on anything and really are
just there to have a good time and see a
story that they already knows right now
it's like a midseason Game of Thrones
episode the way they're just throwing
names it doesn't seem to have been
organized in any real wave or any kind
of coherent like it's not linear but
usually when movies are not in
chronological order there is some kind
of order to the way they've been put
together it's it's the rise and fall or
you're gonna see you know this
background and then you're gonna jump
ahead and then you're gonna see what
happened in the interim or there's some
thought put into it this really feels
like staccato just scenes and moments
from a life jumbled together forehead
like the framing devices have something
I'd like to think if so whoever's in
Kevin Connolly Ephrem entourage
whoever's in his honor whoever the
turtle of his entourage is yes had to
get him the script and it was in order
this may vary in order but then like he
saw a girl or had to vape or something
all the pages flew up and things like Oh
help me put it back together and then
Kevin Connolly loved it and that's how
the movie became there's some some hey
they're like pasta sauce or coffee
stains on it they couldn't read it just
throw that one to the next line you can
read this film could have been in its
exact form script scenes everything a
season of Entourage yes any chase would
have started in this exact movie not
changed to word except you swap out
Travolta for Vinnie chase he's in the
old age makeup this could have been the
movie that was made for fake like the
season of Entourage and I like how you
know you sort of like after watching
those episodes I have a general sense
for like what Vinnie chases many movie
it's not put together in any logical
order that's what this is that's like
the fake season entourage movie put
together and presented like threat level
midnight on the office it has more
narrative we yeah it's gotta say we use
this or I already said that we delete it
we use this joke on solo but like this
is an adaptation of John Gotti's yeah
this is just literally a description of
things that happen with no context or
art or no so many scenes open and close
with characters talking about things we
have no context were like the one that I
remember I does like hey you know he
watched those apartments over on 59th
Street like I don't even know what that
means
oh he wants to use them you're a top
earner
at what well there's a scene where
there's a guy who tells John Gotti son a
story about John Gotti that doesn't
really resolve itself and I knew this is
a no John guy inside of a John Gotti
flashback so I guess he's telling his
son his ghost is remembering the team he
told his son about a guy who told his
son a story from that story which
doesn't really resolve itself to a
courtroom to the end of a trial that we
don't know in the context of yeah we
don't see the arrest we don't know that
he's on trial or for what or why but he
got it as like he got quit the fifth
level of the inception there is that it
flashes back to the courtroom which is a
flashback of an associate of John Gotti
junior which is a flashback of Gotti
talking to Gotti junior which is a
flashback of go Scotty but then that
flashback is is ostensibly John Gotti
juniors friend telling him about the
court trial that his dad had right I
know I know it really just cuts well no
it's it's like davit tell you about
something about your father like it's in
the trailer it cuts from that to the
courtroom and he's in the courtroom the
guy telling us
and then inside of his flashback John
Gotti's voiceover so Chuck is that guy
gas-pipe Casso no no and it's not the
chin either they so they show him being
like you walked around like Junior
soprano but I guess he's faking some
sort of noise for some reason there's
two guys and they don't even show you
which one is the chin comes up there's a
man leaning around another oh man it's
the only shot but no it's it their
scenery comes in from outside he's like
slowly away I want to talk to you about
this wait so he said yeah I think
there's the chin is not as feeble as
he's been major look mass maester
pycelle in-game of threat
alright let's watch got it let's get
gotta get guy
from a company limping towards
bankruptcy the studio behind six bruce
willis movies in the last four years
stable business but restraining order
again totally separate Joe and II from
Ontario comes a film that isn't the
Godfather movie we need but the
Godfather movie we deserve right now
about the time he told his son his life
story
it's a weird way except the person who's
dreaming fell asleep watching Goodfellas
the fight at a bar on Christmas is like
really Christmas the fight in the bar is
settings you would think is setting some
it's his foot says it's the Sun nice
friend and they get him into a bar yeah
and they talk about some stuff and then
a guy says something he's like oh you're
too good to drink with me
oh and then they get to a fight and then
they run away and the cops come and then
John Gotti comes in and the guys they
were fighting gay guys like don't you
know somebody died yeah it's like be
smarter huh and that's it yeah it ties
into nothing else no no that's not
called back it's literally again it's a
Wikipedia page there's no cutting issues
even the Sun dying which by the way very
tragic well it's tragic it's it's tragic
conference tragic but in this movie it's
kind of silly because they cut I counted
they do a full cut from him on the bike
he's driving his bike he got hit by a
car they cut from him to the car and
then back six times yeah I counted it
goes kid car kid one car kid car car kit
car kit car kid car and then it finally
I what's gonna happen if you asked Kevin
Connolly why like what was the goal I
feel like you wouldn't have a good
answer like I feel like a lot of this
was just done to like this is how a
movie got he's completely unaffected by
it he bites his wife for being depressed
yeah what is that what are you doing I
knew that I found that I had already
pulled up about that that billboard oh
that was funny and I'm trying I found it
now I did we did this whole thing once
before so I get what I said when I go
it's much better this time listen trust
me I show you the Billboard this time
we're nailing it yeah anyway keep going
a soulless mob purgatory that feels to
me even the baseline requirements of
storytelling but
forget about it because who needs a
clear hero a message and an insight into
how the mob really worked or coherent
when you've got access that would make
my cousin tomatoes or all the real fans
who sign up arose you could get an echo
New Yorker unless you thought you could
steal from another West Hollywood
Hollywood Silver Lake the valley it's a
large
before I can already hear the yelling in
the comments yes we were talking over
the trailer we did a 45-minute
commentary before this one
it's 87 degrees and this studio video
crashed and jte literally said welcome
back by the way jay-z try to keep this
under 20 or we're gonna lose this one
too I have to start all over again so
this is why you walk you know you know
us you know we don't talk we got to do
the thing you don't like this commentary
we're gonna puck a bus up your ass
sideways I think God he's getting the
commentary it is let's play the deleted
scenes again yes you better play I'm
deleted movies don't talk about sucked
at crime hours ID'd by Obama sucked at
gambling you wouldn't believe how much I
lost last week kept getting busted for
the fourth time in five years repeatedly
threatened his wife talk to that cop of
any cup of tea and read his mafia badly
into the ground and follow my own advice
but he helped an old lady with her
groceries once so I guess he's the hero
of the story Chloe go help come on how
do you steal everything from Goodfellas
except the morale in the entourage guy
direct us in character oh okay that's it
you're trying to tell me that turtle can
get laid quicker than I can story
soprano Fat Tony hey I'm gonna hear the
situation AJ Fredo Gotti this is what
happens when you take roles on
Craigslist
growing up goofy Kelly Preston got cozy
Perez and John Travolta an old age
makeup playing a Meryl was three years
younger than me so hard
Don tirage and honest I can't believe
it's not Goodfellas which one - Joe
Giudice and boom the unfilmable
yeah that's a lot of puns yeah I was
trying to think of another example of an
actor playing a character who's younger
than they are and wearing horrible old
age makeup I can't think of one I have
that that's maybe my favorite monologue
of the years when when John Gotti or
Travolta in the old makeup goes like
they took everything for me they'll
never take my brain oh my heart anyways
what's up there's multiple times where
he's got cuz nobody else matters in this
movie right no one else has any kind of
arc or any kind of screen time doesn't
matter so that multiple times he has
this huge huge monologue and because
there's no other characters of the movie
there's like alright so what are we
doing right so anyway you don't realize
when you first see because that scenes
at the beginning of the movie it's like
the framing device when you get to the
end of the movie you realize he hasn't
seen his son in years they've both been
in prison he knows this is probably the
last time he's gonna get to see his son
and so yep
then you think back and you're like it's
so casual it's like hey how you doing
you ever tell you about the time yeah
it's like they're meeting up for some
random meeting and then you're like
that's the last time you ever to see
your son right it doesn't seem emotional
at all are there anything would you
would you wanna mention the Goldfinger
thing anything we want to loop that lets
see some key bits we we definitely
fleshed out the the season of Entourage
we give you a whole
we was the producer the Bible there is a
scene where they're all we saw a little
bit of in the trailer where they're all
at a table and when you come in and this
is a lot of scenes of Gandhi where you
come in and they're having a
conversation that has nothing to do with
what's happening we assume because they
thought they'd overdub it later with
rice over and in that one scene they are
talking about John Gotti is describing
to his Capo's the plot of the movie
Goldfinger Travolta as John Gotti
summarizing his favorite definitely
watched that of him in front of a rack
of DVD what some guy may sue I didn't
want to live back to Emmett Carla films
they made those who made all the Bruce
Willis movies right good I wa I watched
ten of them yes law and watch ten of
them and I was in a previous life a
logger slash transcriber for a reality
pilot starring one of the two guys that
runs that thing that didn't get picked
up so I've watched hours and hours of
footage of him but I found this picture
that's why I was on my phone I don't
know if we can get any closer on a JT
but there's they put they took out a
huge billboard over Wilshire Boulevard
near Beverly Hills that says I don't
think you can see it well it's can we
zoom it's there we go they are the
leading independent production this is a
huge billboard towering Boulevard
that's the Lucchese Gotti from the
makers a large production projection
see their movies this makes total sits
but they've made some good movies that a
few they produced a few good batting
averages they're co-financing movies
that professional people are making
that's what's happening when they're
involved in a good mood yeah yes so
anyway so yeah if this seemed rushed and
sloppy and a little below our usual
standard then nope it was only because
it was the goddess trailer commentary
that was lost was our Good Fellas yes
and this was our distance our pale
imitation poorly constructed sloppy hard
to hear it all just rather go home yeah
really obligatory more than anything one
thing I will add is that pitbull a very
famous italian-american from now oh yeah
thank goodness they had him work on this
is so appropriate yeah so anyways tune
in next week I'm glad we made it through
this one in fifties in the next five
minutes I'm gonna shoot myself yes thank
you for joining us next week we have a
very special one that you've all been
waiting for a really long so we're very
excited at least one at least one
perhaps two could be a paradox
who knows and reverses it reverse the
polarity first the polarities on our
TriCaster yeah oh boy all right goodbye
good eye
[Music]
you